do you know the number of
cryptocurrencies currently on coinbase
do you know that number it's over a
hundred but it depends it depends what
jurisdiction you're in and you know are
you um
an institution versus retail is like
there's so many different categories now
yeah
so what does it take to become
to to to become an asset to become a
cryptocurrency on coinbase to add
your technology to coinbase
okay well so we're trying to get away
from this idea of being listed on
coinbase as being seen as like an
endorsement or something because
i actually think it's very important
that we are not considered um
judge and jury about you know like
imagine in the early days of the
internet and you were like what's a good
web page and what's a bad web page like
you would have been totally wrong or
anytime
big tech companies try to make these um
review review boards of like you know
apple famously gets in trouble for this
a lot with their app store review
process right and so
something that you think like a
committee of people somewhere thinks
looks silly may turn out to be the next
big thing right and so it's very
difficult so what do we do i mean
we basically have a test of legality
right we check
um
you know do we belie do we believe this
is a security if so it can't be listed
on coinbase and there's a very rigorous
process we go through for that
um just currently the way the laws are
in the u.s you can't you can't do that
and we've been we acquired a
broker-dealer license from the sec we're
trying to work with them to get that
operational and hopefully someday we can
trade real crypto securities but today
that's not possible in the us at least
um then we look at sort of the cyber
security of the the crypto asset does it
do we think there's some flaw in the
smart contract or
you know a way that somebody could um
manipulate it without the customer's
permission
um we look at some compliance pieces to
it as well like the the actors behind it
and like you know their any kind of
criminal history anything like that but
if we believe it meets our our listing
standards basically the this test of um
legality and everything for for customer
protection
then we want to list it because we want
the market to at that point decide and
it's kind of like um
it's kind of like amazon or something
like that where you know it a product
might have three stars or it might have
five stars but
if it starts to get one star
consistently like it's probably a
fraudulent or it's defective or
something like maybe amazon will remove
it but otherwise you want to let the
market decide what these things are
um
so that's generally how we do it and by
the way more and more of these
assets um i think especially like low
market cap assets are going to be traded
on dexes through coinbase it's not that
we
we don't need to list every asset on a
centralized exchange i think dexes are
really good for the long tail and then
it becomes an even
it's even more clear to people like this
is not some endorsement by a coinbase of
like
this assets good and this one's bad like
you know my my belief is there's going
to be millions of these assets over time
and so
um
i hope it doesn't like make news every
time we add one in the future basically
yeah i wonder how you get there because
i even i look to coinbase
for for example you know people as you
could imagine
sort of tag me on twitter or something
like that and all that like
you should interview
our sort of this the the founder of this
particular coin right yeah and i it's so
hard for me to know
what's
first of all what's interesting
technology
what's uh
who's a scammer or not who's actually
legitimately representing an ambitious
new thing versus
a scam
and i you know there's very few sources
of uh
like a verification signal
and unfortunately coinbase in part has
become
a little bit of that too and you're
trying to get away from that because
you're trying to get as many so let let
the people decide so you're thinking of
like amazon star type system
where the people could rate
yeah so i think we'll actually probably
add like user ratings and reviews so um
and and we'll be very cautious about
like you know these are real people um
there's a bunch of stuff we have to do
from that already so i think wisdom of
the crowds is good in terms of getting
feedback on items but we also we're
gonna do our own review which i
mentioned earlier right which is like
okay it meets this minimum bar to be
listed on our site yeah um
i think yeah both are important how do
you know if if a coin is a scam or not
well you can you can see a few things so
you know i hate to use the word scam
because a lot of these these are
judgement calls you got a kind of a
court made me or a jury may land either
way but things that would be red flags
to look at would be
um you know is a bunch of the
asset owned by an insider or insiders um
with short vesting periods
um
you know are
does the background of the founders like
they may have criminal records or if
they've perpetrated other frauds in the
past right
there's a difference between
something which is
just a me too product it's like it
doesn't have anything interesting about
it and something that's an actual fraud
or outright scam and
um
you have to a lot of this data what's
cool about it is that it's now available
on chain you can look at like the
tokenomics behind it and see who owns
economics and are they yeah and are they
selling it you know
in
like inappropriately or are they pumping
it on like youtube and twitter and
making promises about hey the value of
this thing may be higher in the future
and like all those are just big big
no-nos that we would
um
you know we just don't want to go there
so
our whole thing is like we want we want
to enable innovation in this space but
not allow anybody to
curtail the advancement of this industry
by like doing some kind of fraudulent
thing or get rich quick thing so it's a
tricky industry because i'm trying to
figure out who to you know
uh what's interesting to to to to
understand to research yeah and uh it's
hard to know let me ask you about a
trick you want to add to a centralized
exchange which is privacy preserving
cryptocurrency so like monero yeah is
that is that technically difficult or is
that why
why is like monero for example forget
that specific one but like privacy
preserving
cryptocurrency blockchains uh why is
that ever possible to add
so that's that's a great question so the
answer is maybe
so
um
here here's the here's the what the
reason why so
um because we're regulated financial
service business we have various um
licenses to do that we are we are
regulated by various regulators part of
those licenses requires us to have a
quote reasonable um program to monitor
for
suspicious activity um
you know an aml program anti-money
laundering right and so if it if a coin
is 100 anonymous and we can't really do
blockchain analytics to track
um sorts of funds and where these things
might be going
it makes it harder to have a
um a reasonable program around that
that's defensible now there are privacy
preserving coins like zcash which have
something called a view key and a view
key is basically another key which
allows you to de-anonymize the
transactions in specific situations
where you want that so for instance um
you know we do support zcash and one of
the ways we got comfortable with that is
that
when you're buying it on coinbase
um you know you can basically have a
view key the transactions are not
anonymous while you're buying it and we
can see where it goes afterwards and do
our whole standard program
um now if it gets a few hops away down
the road i mean people could eventually
turn on privacy preserving aspects so
you know these are tough judgment calls
but at least in terms of our interaction
with the customer and everything we feel
comfortable at that i think there's a
broader point here which is that i
actually think privacy
coins are a good thing for the world and
we and they should be allowed and more
like you know
despite we've we've made this judgment
call to operate in a regulated and safe
and compliant way but
just taking my coinbase head off for a
minute i think the world would be a
better
place if there were more privacy coins
because it's kind of like the internet
when it first came online like there was
no https everything was http and there
was you know so people were afraid to
put their credit cards on the internet
and um your your messages could be
intercepted and all the stuff and now
the whole internet has basically moved
to https with a little lock icon in your
browser
which is better like and and financial
information is like the most important
information to keep private right
so there's times where like let's say
you're running a charity or something
and you want to have total auditability
transparency for the whole world who
donated and where did the money go
that's great you want it to be public
but if it's like your personal money or
something like that you don't want to be
broadcasting that to the whole world and
in some ways that's what blockchains are
doing
you know pseudonymously because like but
it is a public ledger and so if you can
know who owns each address you can
basically deanonymize it
i you know i think basically the people
should fight for um privacy and freedoms
of all kind but privacy of money is a
good thing
you